the issue should not be government it
should not be unalloyed and unlimited
idolatry of personal property which is
the path that the libertarian movement
has gone down hi i'm tim cavanaugh for
Reason TV we're here with David Brin the
author of the renowned science fiction
books The Postman the uplift series and
many others David thank you for joining
us oh it's great Tim love reason you are
self-identified as a libertarian or have
been in the past you're often like tweak
libertarians and you're Ted address a
while back you said that libertarians
are right about something but they
follow mine ran down the path of as you
said well it's kind of equal Rand and
Rothbard nice I I personally think this
is the wrong path for the movement I
happen to believe that the issue should
not be government it should not be
unalloyed an unlimited idolatry of
personal property which is the path that
the libertarian movement has gone down
the greatest creative force in the
universe is fair but creative
competition it's what made us in in
nature it's not always fair but in the
balance of a decent ecosystem it has a
certain circle of life fairness to it
libertarians need to be reminded that
across 6,000 years the greatest enemy of
free enterprise of market enterprise
innovation creative competition have
always been oleg arks the pyramidal
social structure with a few lords at the
top dominating everyone else for their
own self-interest their own reproductive
self-interest it was in their interest
to make sure that their position was
inherited and their children did not
have to compete even if they were great
competitors well it did deal with it in
the modern context though I mean I want
my kids to inherit as much as they
possibly can and a there's there's
little danger that I'm gonna be able to
lock out everybody else from inheriting
whatever royalty I have to pass on so it
all right you know isn't to fight now
really this sort of urge toward mass
equality and everybody you know with
inheritance taxes and on up you're doing
your job your job is to be a libertarian
and to fight for non-government
solutions to problems and to fight for
the market to limit the regulation to
the minimum that it needs to be the
tragedy of libertarianism is that it's
not playing that function in the modern
political landscape because it keeps
being marginalized by the lapell
grabbers the Roth Burtis the rand pardon
me the aynd
nevermind I don't want to be insulting
the fact of the matter is that when you
get 1% 1% 1% 1% 1% 1% at an era when the
right in the Republican Party has
clearly gone start gibbering insane then
something is wrong with your message
here's the point about liberals they
don't want to equalize outcomes deep
inside they want to equalize the playing
field the starting blocks for all
children at age 25 to have had enough
protein enough education enough health
so that they can enjoy fully enter the
competitive capitalist marketplace Adam
Smith wanted that he would have
disagreed with some of the more
socialist lefty ways that's our job as
libertarians get into the mix negotiate
fight for the most enterprise-oriented
solutions you're the author of the
transparent society that was one of the
early works to say the age of privacy
that we have known is sort of coming to
an end and that may be the future of
that won't be so bad what do you think
it's happened since then we've had the
USA PATRIOT Act we've had you know
controversies around what are what is
private and your phone records we have
also on the other side seen WikiLeaks
the transparent society is one of the
only public policy books from the 20th
century that's not only still in print
that's selling more every year the
publishers are deeply puzzled and may in
part be because of
2:06 I got all these emails P 206 in
which there's this Twilight Zone moment
in which from 1997 I say well let's
suppose some day terrorists ever bring
down world both World Trade Center
towers what will the Attorney General
ask for because of the ratchet effect
when the public is fearful and the are
paid protector caste asks for more
powers to see there is a ratchet effect
and I'm sorry libertarians it is going
to happen here's the key about 1984 in
the telescreen it's not that the Big
Brother can look at the people it's that
it's one way if Big Brother has all the
power all the force all the police all
the guns but it's all both ways and the
people can see everything that the party
members are saying that dictatorship is
not gonna last more than another
generation looking up at the mighty from
below who will watch The Watchmen quispe
so custodiat custody is we must watch
The Watchmen we should draft 10,000
average Americans every year into a pool
you refuse you're out then you do
security clearances on them you get 1000
left loyal security clearance willing to
keep their mouths shut and you unleash
them with a badge that lets them in any
door and I mean any door in the United
States of America would include area 51
any door they can walk in and there are
penalties they spend a month in jail if
they let if they say anything about
anything they've seen and there's no
exception of the month in jail but if
they see something heinous the month in
jail is worth it to them huh okay our
great inland Enlightenment institutions
democracy markets courts and science all
flourish exactly to the degree that all
the participants know what's going on
and they die to the degree that they are
robbed of light duh and now you see why
I'm a libertarian I want this to work I
want it to be competitive in terms of
both genetic modification and in the
uplift books you is there any question
of informed
if you went to the insects right now and
said we're gonna make you more
intelligent they could make a pretty
good case so we have a form of
intelligence that's not you know that's
our own and it is one of the best
questions I've been asked in in months
in uni new year so the minute somebody
tries to meddle in the genes of advanced
creatures like chimps or dolphins
I mean people read the uplift books and
they they see the after effects 200
years in the future I should first
explain that I'm not the first person to
do that Pierre Boulle a Planet of the
Apes cordwainer Smith HG Wells the
island of dr. Moreau but all of those
which dr. Moreau is obviously the hero
well this is not a pleasant guy in all
of those cases they went for the simple
morality tale that we create these
creatures in order to enslave them I
decided that's been done so in my uplift
universe it's 200 years from now we've
done this with the best of intentions
we've uplifted dolphins given them that
last leg up so they can use machines
they can talk to us and people look at
that outcome and they and then they say
oh cool great but then they stop and
they think amazing what is going to be
involved in starting this program and
there's one answer it starts with P pain
and the pain that several generations of
dolphins and chimps would have to go
through in order for their descendants
to be these members of a civilization
that's wise and benefits from them and
that gives them the chance to pilot
starships this is going to result in
both the right for fundamentalist
reasons and the left for goody-two-shoes
empathy reasons crushing any conceivable
effort to engage in this uplift process
and the only way around it is where your
question comes in informed consent
Lois Herman's work at the University of
Hawaii with several captive dolphins by
far the best
report to me the Dolphins are eager
given a chance to go away they come back
but they get frustrated when they fail
at a task they can tell that they were
too stupid for the task and they throw a
fit and they sulk in my opinion that's
implied consent that's their saying I
can't understand what you humans are
saying and I know it's really
interesting I'd like to understand
better but you're absolutely right about
your next question Tim is that just me
subjectively interpreting because I'd
like to interpret it that way
absolutely I don't know this is the kind
of fascinating moral quandary we should
have as we pick up God's tools and
become co-creators well david brin
thanks a lot for joining us it's great
to be here and as a heretical
libertarian I'm still one of you guys
fantastic thanks a lot for reason TV I'm
Tim Cavanaugh